[Music]
what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation it is time for genv
episode 3 today John how's it going it's
going great sir how are you no no
generation joke Coy how are you
generally speaking very well there we go
now we got it ladies and gentlemen you
know what to do leave a like on this
video be sure to subscribe click the
notification Bell when a reaction for
genv episode 4 is up here on this
channel we have been very much enjoying
this show episode 1 and two if you did
not catch a reaction to that that is
obviously in existence here
fighting the YouTube restrictions it's
it's a fun time here the real rejects
right now also full length through and
watch along resn with your own copy of
genv available for super sex rejects
over at our patreon page over there we
cover several shows exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch SS
included massive thank you to all who
have joined us thus far it's one of the
absolute greatest ways to support the
Channel unduly all right let's do
[Music]
it
underwire bras
shoelaces
oh I was Wonder I was thinking this was
the exact same location yeah that's how
they tell
us whoa wait a minute he's been aware of
brainwashed every time to forget him
Sam did you know about this compound V
stuff no how could mom and dad do that
to us they thought they were giving us
Powers I got a broken [__] brain oh I
could have just been regular man this
show really shows you the suffrage of
being a super drug or no drug you'd
still be weird
as it really does feel like the mutant
High version of the bo yeah it really
does
yeah Sam stop it
okay yikes
dude nice
it's a Mortal Kombat fatality try
legitimate so you must get brainwashed
every time to forget I'm guessing go to
sleep Jes oh her memory's been wiped too
Andre I'm fine really I just pushed too
many people that's so their subconscious
keeps it so they dream about it maybe I
mean it sounds like they push their
minds down her ability to enchant seems
like she's been Enchanted too brilliant
idea to ping my phone and then save me
from my Stone Cold idiocy I hope these
two fall in love it's happening we need
to get them out now if you charge in
there you're going to get caught and
then God knows what and then and think
about it for a second no you know if you
guys just did it you'd calm down a lot
of friction and pressure just alleviated
please don't do anything stupid I can't
lose you
too oh it begins the road to doing
it I love trauma bonding you know where
the magic
happens Luke died like 2 days ago yeah
but they're teenagers their hormones
crazy time works differently in the TVA
can she push him last for like hours oh
yeah like keep him under like Dread like
a nine enchant him to be yeah out here
oh no she's Madam plasma to
me oh wow oh my God
no a brave mave
bar you eat to get big to get small you
you must have the most regulated diet
it's funny because every time I react I
have to
defecate every time I read the comments
it makes me
def no it's not an eating disorder it's
how I get small you hear that YouTube
yes my mom knows yes I'm in control
you're in control stop whenever I want
that's why you're the size of a gummy
bear maybe you should take a break talk
to someone get help okay and you
yourself are you going to take a break
get help that's different that's my
power right thank
you you're proven her point but I've
been pied by half the school today I'm
not pitying you okay Marie we don't have
to do this we could just focus on
classes like you said we can just be
roommates okay it's interesting how
their powers are so rooted in self harm
specifically these two and like would
that cause their personality you think
their personality ties their power like
I'm always nature nurture with powers
cycal I'm sorry I'm aware you're not
five it's force of habit my daughter
Loved These pure evil you have a
daughter I did I wanted to tell you
after that interview last night I'm so
proud of you Marie you did the right
thing Marie when that bottle blonde
ambushed you with that [__] about your
sister it was on Purpose By the way
because it's better ratings if you cry
on camera but you didn't let her get
stayed tough showed Poise ratings real
low I feel like it's probably true I
want you to come with me to this Brink
fundraiser tonight can meet some alumni
big donors I've never been just smile
let them drone on about themselves no
pressure yeah so she definitely um did
some experimentation on her daughter huh
oh yeah 100% that happened I'm just the
girl who was
there she's just a
freshman note the tremble to the voice
strong and
humble steon back there you're coming
with me to the fundraiser tonight and
you're going to butter the ass of every
trustee with your tongue yeah if I could
do something heroic like help people
that'll be good if there's a camera
pointed at you yeah got to do it for the
ratings got to do the photo not the
heroism there is financial gain always
clicks Emma oh Ron Layman Emma wait up
hold on a second look I I want to see if
the this campus is at all affected by
homelanders recent actions though the
greater World building of like I mean
yeah how season 3 ended yeah I had no
right to co-opt your story okay I
apologize I don't trust
you
wow you filming this I want everyone to
know how sorry I
am wow my hero now's the perfect time to
vomit are you keeping your food L yes
Mom I am completely balanced you look an
inch or two shorter than usual so you
might need to add 50 calories okay I'm
just I'm just going to check your height
goodness this is the exact mom she would
have the mom's jacket is a tribute to
April or Neal or Jubilee
Easter egg all the above got it there it
is just want to curl up and everyone
just when your father left me for that
bir to a child or when I was fired from
the bot Shopping Network did I curl up
and wanted to say I'm sorry Luke was so
nice to me thank God you single-handedly
stop that Monster's murderous
frenzy yeah dude what did you expect you
saw the interview everyone
intervie I mean come on come on M
I know Luke was no that's just it you
didn't know Luke how funny he was how
much he loved his family how hot his
best friend
[Laughter]
is this can't be real this is very
uniquely structured I love how much
Luke's still in the show through
flashbacks yeah I haven't seen the show
13 but I feel like it feels like this
1 yeah oh God yeah
probably she would have never Le violent
I should have been there oh they told me
kill himself they convinced him he that
old tell me to feel
better I don't want to feel like this I
think this is something you just have to
go through I'm sorry what a [__] I was
going to say how emotionally mature how
did not use her power with the make with
the pushing
already just a second who's
that it's my parents
I didn't even
finish okay do it in the closet man you
can go through walls
yeah does he have to travel through
walls naked or can clothes go with him
is he ever doing it and accidentally
goes through the
girl I wonder if they like them better
as a boy or a girl she changes they
change I dat both H we wanted to pay our
respects to Brink tonight we know what
he meant to you he thought you were such
an upstanding young man jeez
bit on those deep books think deep oh
the a trainers those are magnificent
they're signed you know they sign the
bottom though so it wears off pretty
quick but you know it's
there good to know he would sign the
bottom don't wear
those she's even more Perfectly
Imperfect in person you found a real one
real ones John Bernthal man the women
are just used and abused in this show
after this Golden Boy mess I'm not sure
how much I'm pledging the focus on white
male Heroes is problematic if you want
more like
Marie I don't know if you have
representation yet but here's my card
here's my card culture War to get an N
of my card oh too late guys you missed
the window just crashed and
burned lucky Jordan doesn't have laser
eyes with Luke gone this freefor all for
number one is going to get ruthless and
you have a Target on your back you uh
put it there I don't know you could be
the first top ranked freshman in
history oh her ambition just coming to
bite her is rough to see this is
Courtney Courtney she is a senior
producer at V last night's interview
with your roommate Marie oh Marie's your
roommate oh I didn't know that yeah real
bottled lightning there huh she wants to
talk to you about maybe starring in her
next reality TV show but no one knew
about the tragic underbelly sorry tragic
underbelly it's a Rebrand oh it's a
complete and total Rebrand oh God it's
an
exploitation you'll love it she's
battling her own sort of internal super
villains from the body oh that is
disturbing eating disorder yes oh that
is so cruel yeah isn't that stuff all a
little personal I want emotion I want
real
pain she's great I hate her every
executive eaten alive or feeling
[Laughter]
small oh man I excuse me I have
to I have to vomit for non-power
relation having met you I love the
falsehood and the capitalistic
exploitation of people's emotions that
this show really shines a light on oh so
on the surface but I've been in those
meetings Kyle Vogler you have a fine kid
a real go-getter don't let him you it
was a holy Terror as a
boy we're from Rochester where are you
from Kyle how much they're just like
saying boy and and like instigating that
narrative is he expected to present his
male Jordan at these things I think so
are they expected to present as male
Jord my bad I hate you are part of the
problem petress thanks how do you be in
it you don't
ever a
I'm really sorry Emma we've all been
there I don't want to just be roommates
and I don't pity you yeah she wants a
friendship I love the setting that
they're having this conversation holding
her underwear through a dress in a stall
like
a
friends I love this show I don't know if
I can I release release
Marie just let
it
oh the tinkle C Jordan used to chase
Ruby around the playground trying to
kiss her try getting away with that this
day until one day Ruby whacks him clean
in the face what I really like that this
show is also showing when we learn that
the parents were the ones who agreed to
give their kids compound V you are
seeing how the the destruction of the
kids not having a choice in any of this
and how it deteriorates them and just
how cruel the parents are oh and then
the reaction used to try dresses
together in high school so maybe we can
be wife and wife sorry about this he can
get dramatic nothing to apologize for
he's into it you got a great kid here
just going to let you catch up he's not
into
it I mean like why can't it be like
inspirational I mean not like Queen mave
but I mean like Queen mave you know
people like the drama maybe you're not
like ohol Mom I mean it's exploiting me
I think in the real world everybody uses
everyone and I think that this could
help you in a million
ways thank you wow no I mean
yes should taught me how to do it how to
stick my fingers down my go yourself
holy [__] this is fan [__] tasting
that's good reality TV yeah that's what
I'm
saying it should be about them stage
moms you you you push somebody for the
few boo yes yes I
did should we talk about our intercourse
situation sorry that sounded yes not not
now not now later not a near shot of my
dad think they have chemistry I think
they're not supposed to but do and
they're supposed to like in pieces you
know what I mean I think it's calculated
I guess I I'm aware they're acting when
they have scenes together yeah so it's
not even really a chemistry question
you're my firstborn son the day you were
born was the best day of my life I
thought we were giving you a gift gift
with compound V you did give me a gift
oh I get a lot of kids don't have a
choice but you do wow you can be a boy
forever if you
want sometimes I think you change into a
girl just to spite me I was wait exactly
for that L waiting exactly for that line
the kid addicted to their PlayStation
close to Olive Garden just for the bread
sticks who've been just Property
Brothers I've never changed Dad I've
always
just been me exactly just themselves
what a way to address this with
superpowers man and this guy just saying
all the so they're all going to kill
their parents by the end of the season
right I think the episode that's the key
to self-acceptance right
[Music]
yes like what all I got is this and what
Luke told me before Mur it's not exactly
credible find out where they have Luke's
brother but I can't do it without
getting busted but you can but
maybe oh [__] bading idea so you should
forget I said no I'm totally totally in
dude wow like life or death dangerous
and you're freshman but she's being
asked to use her powers to solve a crime
actual heroism
yeah wow okay so the GPS tags connect to
my phone remember just Recon no tiny
action hero [__] I think this is where
they're keeping him but if you see
anything shady just bail got it get it
got it good
yeah I'm just still stoned sweet Jesus
oh you must be extra it's like one glass
of champagne but
trunk she on the
tray it's got an Noir poster up eat some
peas whoa that's
scary oh no Jesus how did you not notice
him you
what a shot our beloved Brink's death
was not just a trag where the H you go I
was getting some hair dark days in the's
history some dank air in darkness Stars
can truly shine like Marie Maro the
guardian of gulin oh boy and Jordan's in
the room what happened to you
parents vodka the expensive [__] you
save for the big swing in and two
glasses you still pay for
it free vodka you got to be real
specific it's like communicating with
chpt wow you think they'd have better
video editor n man just throw it all
into Windows Movie
Maker Brink didn't just tone my skills
he sharpened my mind he turned me into
the Curious intelligent man oh my god oh
yeah squid curious Brink was like an
uncle to my boy one of the real ones hey
what do you thinking know this is my
moment did I do something to piss you
off I didn't sleep through my interview
there's some Fu up Sho going on and that
that's why Luke killed Brink because
there's there's this underground
hospital where they keep everybody
in who else would be told
oh NOS don't say anothering word about
this great like super tight shot too oh
when they decide to go intimate with
their camera you know so powerful they
make oh oh fear oh that switch he does
love his son man a tiny girl is such an
interesting choice why would I do that
what does it
mean no I'm I'm real prove it what's the
name of the stuff the animal I love more
than anything when I was little I have
no idea what's your name dip how about
dip
dipt on a
bike no
man favorite movie well you're a white
guy
so Godfather Star Wars or sha shank all
[Laughter]
three Water World water a man of taste
you're real yes for real holy [__] you
do know this is the dumbest test ever
right what are you what are you doing
here you could get in big trouble now
they have chemistry yeah truly
immediately to get you out of hereu no I
don't I don't think so you were
literally almost in a dungeon it's not
so bad I've tried to get out before but
people get hurt I get mixed up I just I
started some new meds I think it's
better if I stay here thanks for coming
by stoping again your brother sent me
Luke it's like you're either a hero or a
self-imposing threat to society he wants
to get you out so I mean I guess I could
give you the codes to all the security
doors
you know the
codes yeah dude come on man I love their
interaction but he's got a million imp
pledges Superstar you save my ass your
ass needed saving you slipped after
Golden Boy the donations were going down
the toilet and so was I then one look at
that smile of yours and their wallets
just cracked right open Ki has that
effect I'm glad I could be useful to you
oh so useful you're fantastic excuse me
oh welcome to VA put it together who
gave that info to the woman on TV I'm
surprised you can walk straight with
everyone's tongue lodged up your ass
leave me alone [__] about me brown noser
one uper mommy and daddy's perfect
little hero oh now you yeah well that's
definitely not me because my parents are
dead because I killed them yikes you
happy [__] wow I didn't know I had
powers until my first period I couldn't
control the blood and it sliced through
through my mom's body dad came in same
deal I'm the last person who thinks
they're a hero I [__] hate myself half
the time and I just spent the entire
night being dragged around like a show
Pony so I'm not in the mood for your
[__] pan to the other girl recording all
of
this put it online you got real trauma
you can sit with us trauma sit with us
we are the weirdos Mister we were
camping I was nine my parents were
setting at the tent my little brother
kept kicking at my shins I grabbed him
by the arm and I told him to go away and
never come back oh oh
no walked right into the woods that was
the first time my power showed up
oh is he just out there did he die not
to have that kind of
power your parents shot you up with a
dangerous drug when you were a baby to
make a buck off you no my parents
weren't like that yes they were
everyone's parents are in this universe
some people might have come I killed my
grandpa with my Powers what no you
didn't change it to a boy and yeah I
know I was just feeling left
out change it to a girl and you had a
heart attack I see going for that joke
so much more than that it's about being
alone at the end of the world and
finding your
Humanity water worlds yes and drinking
your own
[Laughter]
he reminds me of Evan Peters a lot see
you whenever hope so me too oh she found
a real connection you want some oh can't
if I eat
I like Alice in Wonderland hey you're
soing brave thanks you've gotten closer
to rescuing me than Luke ever did the
pretty thing you were probably born with
or maybe cosmetic
surgery oh no
hide
smaller what did you do it's about her
roommate Emma oh it's all coming
together now they're a team as soon as
they turn off the electricity run what
electricity oh poor kid face off Andor
prison and face
off
fire some
time
oh
uh-oh uh-oh oh what are you doing
kiddo what are you doing H yes do
something disgusting holy Christ Thanos
yeah Thanos Thanos take a candy bar go
his ear butt go into his
ear yes do
it bra
well she does anything to eat unless she
eats his brain yeah go for
it did she bring corn what What's happen
she can still Tinker around in there
she's going through yeah she doesn't
need a she doesn't need to go big she
can still like mess with some wires oh
just eat some of his brain tissue I love
them they're my two favorite pairing all
the supporting characters are
immediately like
fascinating this is the grossest thing
possible
oh I think he did it yeah
100% yes so
bad sweet oh
man man oh boy all
right um wait did I pause it too early
something we missed something in episode
one all right was it post credit scene
uh it was like a um the Ashley was
saying something to the camera and then
it was it was something special they
shot but then it Segways into a preview
for oh episode two for for the rest of
the season God I don't want to see yeah
so I was like the the thing we missed
was the exclusive thing got uh but I'm
glad we missed it yeah I'd rather watch
the show yeah yeah uh oh yeah that was
great in love with the show have you
guys seen uh have you guys seen runaways
yeah big fan it was the first time I
felt like an adult because I was time
like I understood the parents born than
the kids the Kristen Stewart movie oh I
love that too you know that's
runaways seems like there would be a lot
of different things called that big Joan
Jet fan he's just like this relates Jo
jet not AEL rock and roll when I come in
the man it's a weird tangent but I'm in
ch no runaways is a a really good like
the two sets of protagonist show they
wrote it really well yeah I think that
there I think this is the way how we
liking boys to a bunch of other shows
and movies and and mix in with
commentary I feel like this is what it's
doing before I mean it's College when
normally you associate that with like
high school sure these other stuff uh
but no I thought this was great I mean a
lot of things we talked about during the
reaction itself that I feel like this
show is further uncovering like it
doesn't seem like it's trying it no no I
don't want to say I'm making it sound
like they're not putting effort because
it's effortless at what it's doing yeah
it it doesn't feel like they're forcing
anything in here if they're they if
anything they are just magnifying other
elements that have already been
established in their other show and
really showcasing that significantly
more you know like the way how they have
touched on like the par the the the
relationship that they have with
Starlight and her mom was probably the
closest we got to getting a sense of
what the parent child relationship was
like but of also how tough that can be
and it's like depending on what class
you are in uh in society financially of
how that can inform your decision you
know if you so there's a that was one
aspect and here you really do get to see
just how tortured uh it can be growing
up and then how they form the these
children to morph into a personality
that is not really them like when you
get to the boys and you see the seven
and then as that show progresses it's
constantly about peeling back the layer
of everyone there and you see that all
of them are just broken depressed
individuals who are not really in tune
with the real versions of themselves and
hear you you're you're stripping that
all back to see the creation you see the
seeds plantet of how that like this is
Origins and and what I what this episode
did for me in terms of universe building
in term because of the mystery because
one thing we were talking about uh last
episode was I'm not super into to the
mystery just yet I'm kind of waiting to
see what it's ultimately going to pay
off into and what I think this set up at
least for me this is the school where
everyone goes to before they can even
have a shot at becoming a Super uh you
know one that gets to work if you're not
part of the seven or if you're going to
be part of some other team or just have
some kind of job or you know this is
where you have to first go through and
now the boys they have already delved
into uncovering vot the corruption there
a lot of that being uh given to the
public even the the whole thing with
compound
V and this is something that they have
to keep sacred because people still want
to go to the school people still want to
feel like I can become a superhero and
stuff and the people who gave their kids
compound V they need them to go through
here to make something of themselves and
this is the season now that they are
going to do expose the corruption and
the evilness and the and the the the the
abuse that this school does and this
school That's essential to the boy
Universe right right so it's another
thing they are
up yeah like this is an essential
ingredient for the future of the supers
you know what I mean like for for to
have any more supers in the future and
especially when you have the boys which
is all about stopping the supers at
least I'm like you know Butcher and
everyone else so I think that as a World
building this is an essential viewing
experience mixed in with just great
drama great drama great storytelling and
um
relatable uh I keep wanting to say the
tech they qualify as teens young adult
teen struggles you know well I mean the
freshmen are still technically teens
yeah yeah and I I think they do an an
absolute excellent job and capturing
that loneliness that adolescent angst uh
I I I really think that as a as a boy
Universe show it's very much Essential I
could see how it could fact into the
bigger picture as as opposed to just a
spin-off you know yeah
I no please I I think that like as
spin-offs go enriching is always better
like uh it's kind of like with 3D I I
hate when 3D does that thing where it
like here's an arrow launching at you
but when it does like you go deeper into
the frame it's way more interesting like
it's like looking into a book and this
is doing that narratively it's giving us
a deeper worldview it's enriching world
all the things you were just saying but
what I think I'm most impressed by is
every single episode you're introduced
to an entire swarm of new characters and
they're immediately written so well
acted so well and cast so well you hate
or love them so immediately and and I
really like the comic I said I think on
episode two um it introduces entire
teams sometimes in an issue it's it's a
book where if you flip a page you've got
a person that within four frames you're
like I have to know enough about them to
care this is doing that as a show and
I'm really impressed that every time we
we build on an episode us hating
Jordan's parents makes us more indear to
her which makes that scene of the three
of them talking more interesting us
fearing for the dad's fear of what's
going to happen to his son makes us more
invested in Aon and I think that what
they're doing is every single episode is
just going deeper and deeper and deeper
so I I don't still care about the
mystery but I know that when they flip
the switch I'm going to because by that
point I care about all the pieces of the
puzzle so much here's why I think it's
important why the mystery is so
important um if I could just make one
last point about it is
that whenever you're with the seven and
something is happening with VA what does
the seven do they protect it they fight
to cover it up their top rated students
you saw it with Golden Boy you see it
with everyone here they're not
interested in protecting yeah yeah
they're interested in uncovering and
potentially exposing the truth the
question is will they Expose and I think
a lot of that relies heavily on Marie
like is which side is she going to go
down right yeah and is she going to be a
contributor to the to the exposing part
of it she or are we going to watch her
morph into being like Oh you be a
perfect candidate for this time because
you will conceal our secret and that's
what I'm I'm enjoying with the pivots
every Arc is like do they go this way do
they go this way and by the end of the
episode you're like I don't know but I
know the more like you know the person
more but I like that we're still
zigzagging yeah so I think that that's
why this could be very much crucial
that's it's not really like like okay to
me it seems like okay they're
experimenting down their on te okay yeah
this is like nothing really that
different then we we maybe there's more
to it but that's kind of what I what it
what I gather it seems kind of that
cliche of what we already saw in like
the boys already you know like like yeah
they're they have prisoners and they're
experimenting and exactly why I don't
know they're developing something new to
maybe harness or whatever uh but what
it's doing with our main character
of what our main the damage our main
charact because there our main is in the
boys it's the the boys themselves and
supers and the supers our lead supers
are are also the boys you know they are
doing the the um the mission of that
yeah so that to me makes for very
compelling um you know putting up
putting a hole in in the in the vault
plans uh but Johnny please sorry I know
I not stopped talking about
no it's all good I mean everything you
guys have said I I would Echo entirely
and I think that with the central
mystery it's kind of I still feel
similarly to how I did before where it's
like it's a world where you know there's
a nefarious plot at hand and it's more
about using that to give the characters
you know interesting ways to develop and
confront the scenario and show who they
are and uh and I appreciate especially
after this three episode chunk you know
where we're left off because we are left
with this moment of like you know bad
things have happened and a lot of you
know significant events have gone down
um but like you know the the cat isn't
quite out of the bag and the [__] hasn't
quite hit the fan yet but I could see
how now this could certainly be that
moment because with em yeah oh I see
what you did there I I understood that
reference uh but yeah like with Emma you
know in this completely compromised
situation where it's either gonna get
worse for Sam and or worse for her too
um I think you know that's just like a
great kind of compelling start
especially then when you have that
combin uh combined moment of Andre's dad
being like you drop this you know do not
pursue this I probably have sh like the
last shot was the Cliffhanger I was
wondering where it would end for all
this buildup why it was three episodes
and not only did it look like a piece of
Derrick Robertson art Who's the artist
and the boys but it also puts us in like
now we're into the second act of the
structure of like things are going to
get worse and conflict is rising well I
mean beyond that too the Marie join
she's now like being welcome I mean
there's a team forming for now they
exact that's what was getting me like
runaways Vibes you know or like teen
high school show like a teen
show this episode though especially The
Runaways parenting makes sense because
yeah you're so focused on both tiar and
the interplay between both and all the
parents kind of have even though it's
not the same coordinated
villainy an heir of coordinated villainy
what I'm so impressed by is that we
there's like what eight leads and I keep
like when you made the joke of uh and
then just to the right she's filming
like that's believable I really enjoy
how well-versed all the supporting
characters are that I'm like this could
build on this could build on this or not
and I really like that it doesn't feel
like it's coloring in the numbers like
watching this show I don't know how the
episode's going to end but I also don't
know how the second and third Act of
each episode's going to be and it's
actually captivating throughout like
I've really struggled lately with
television cuz my attention Pain's
getting worse by the day and like I
haven't once felt compelled to check my
phone I haven't once felt compelled to
think about the world like this show is
like the boys has kept me so engaged
that the world outside this screen is
null and void for the runtime and that
is so rare in in entertainment right now
for me yeah I agree I agree I was I'm
really sucked into it when it's when
it's all um unfolding and it's minute by
minute it's not it's not like oh just
the last five minutes are like oh but
it's the whole show is like what's going
to happen yeah and I think it's a smart
thing too that they that they do hearken
toward things you said 13 Reasons Why
especially with the Golden Boy plot line
no I mean like from from from the vague
amounts I know from listening to whyms
rant about seasons of 13 recent just
like I think there's like flashbacks and
stuff totally and uncovering a mystery
and like that's I didn't expect him to
stay in the show so much but yeah the
flashback getting there yeah it's a
solid device but I think also this show
is nicely pitched in that yeah it's
using its perspective very
conscientiously but yeah it's also able
to without just being a ripoff of
various other teen and young adult shows
embody that too to feel you know
adjacent to and certainly well within
the graphic graphic novel uh you know
sense of the boys but also yeah to
occupy this separate tonal space that is
yeah pitched like I could see it's like
if you're a boys fan I I feel like
you'll definitely check this out but I
could see some people getting into the
boys through this through this yeah
especially the younger like next wave of
because I remember being this age and
feeling isolated and then like these are
my best friends and then back to
isolated these my best friends and the
show is capturing that but I also
remember being really pandered to by
adults that hasn't changed for I mean
that's just life but but like I remember
being in your like late teens early 20s
where you felt like everyone was kind of
pandering to like yeah you're an adult
now and then you're like but why don't
you let me do [__] like this feels a lot
like that and especially in this parent
episode where you can tell the moment
where they're like you're just using me
or like this is being and obviously like
I said last week it's a bigger scale
because it's a superhero show but I love
how that alienation also feels like how
do the parents manipulate what they want
into getting their kid what they want
yeah and I I do kind of Wonder I mean
from a business Optics perspective
because it's gen V they're pitching as
like the the you know it feels like
you're watching young adults on screen
and I don't know if that might cause a
distance for audiences you know uh upon
before watching it like oh is this
targeted for a younger demographic this
time you know because like everyone on
the boys is like like in their 30s and
right and that where they're focusing
here that's just one question that pops
up the other thing that I really like is
the message that every Disney movie
pushes now which is about you know uh
don't listen to your parents
yep chart your own path they're out to
get you and uh three Luke uh I think
they did an excellent job with him here
because I thought he was just going to
show the way they've handled the
perspective on when you see Luke is he's
just deranged he's kind of crazy right
now he's cracked and then when she shows
up with him you're like oh never mind
yeah they even introduce him upon her
perspective Sam Luke luk one to die yeah
Sam's the one yeah my bad um names are
out of the three of us worst Sam yeah
Sam you think he's scary and and that
he's he he can be like Manic and maybe a
threat unhinged and then even when um
again Emma tiny uh
Emma Emma when she shows up even she's
terrified and the way they capture it oh
that shot through the cup to the cup
yeah that I now see a spider's POV every
time I might put a spider in thing I'm
like I know what it's like bro but it
captures it captures it in a way like oh
he's terrifying but then as she gets to
know him you know you just see this boy
who's who's uh broken yeah L you see
this sweetness and and you could and it
makes sense why they would bond with
each other like oh never mind they're
just a couple of misunderstood and like
you said like their trauma bonding felt
real immediately like I loved their
trauma bonding right way yeah I just
love trauma bonding I mean you got the
right show for it the right Universe for
it the boys and gen a lot of trauma
bonding any other bonding is boring
super surf level can't B through love
Disney movies Bond over pain have you
met someone without trauma my God
they're not funny boring they have no
personality they probably have their
life together I don't
care car live in LA that's for sure so I
don't know him the the the interest is
in the struggle all my friends that are
doing well back East with kids and stuff
love to death lack of conflict in your
life got that white pick fence go live
your life over there you stay sane we're
going to watch genv and Trauma bond with
it I'm so impressed man this show is
like up there with the boys and I think
the boys is one of the best things to
come out of TV in the last few years so
this is really impressive if this sticks
The Landing like this feels like one of
those shows where it can prove spin-offs
can be good much the way that like there
was that that phase where sequels were
so bad I was like look a good sequel
like this could be like remember
spin-offs like this is so well put
together what it makes me wonder about
the writer room too because it does feel
authentically youthful and in tune with
the youth without feeling like you know
greetings fellow children right you know
so and the language doesn't feel like
it's heavy-handedly like trying to be
young but it's also not stale No Cap Coy
No Cap No Cap don't be sus this is this
is this show is straight
busing alrighty guys all righty Coy I
got to get you out of here good Boogie
so ladies and gentlemen what did you
think about this third episode of the
Gen V leave your thoughts leave your
thoughts down below um thank you guys
for being here and for being citizens of
the reject Nation get yourself some
reject Peril thanks Coy we will see you
guys next week where we also got Loki
yeah oh we're back wait a minute L on
Thursday this on Friday I mean this is
Friday at midnight this Friday midnight
that's spicy all right oh Friday
midnight all right remember rest you
don't dude Saturday no rest is not a vo
vocabulary gief you this is a
retroactively sponsored by the midnights
will be I've gone back to just grabbing
old cans that I haven't thrown out yet a
little
down just throw them all into one big
bucket and I'll just dump it on my
head
what's up our uh 10 and UPS we have
asked our uh chat TBT here to uh Mar you
guys a shout out with Rhymes that
incorporate a movie title or character
or TV series let's see what they have
come up with take it away John
absolutely saury like Furby in Gremlins
creating Buzz that's all whims ooh Ryan
Smith smooth as myth in Troy revealing
the pith Adrien Tims bopping to hims in
Sister Act all about again the whims
real nagas like real sagas it's Star
Wars full of
Dramas had their gear bringing cheer
like cheers clear as
beer Ian Simon shining like a diamond in
Oceans 11 with Vibes so vibrant s High
Glover like Clover and lucky number
seven back uh bringing luck over and
over lucky number
s gota watch it Kayla the king like
Leila singing and Almost Famous her vibe
is ringing Allan Ling hey even that
rhymes like bling in The Bling Ring
sparkling and
zinging Kelsey like Gatsby in The Great
Cat be classy and Sassy Kar like Tiara
in The Princess Diaries sparkling with
aura Eric K 39 like Con in the con is on
striking like
ions my head hurts nickx like flicks in
netflex flashing those peex nice Juan
Longoria like Euphoria and Euphoria
spreading the glory
I love the character of euphoria on
Euphoria static and like a tent in Mash
so content Cliff Rodriguez like whiz in
The Wizard of o saring in the bids oh
they could have done better oh goat
Nation 18 like rotation in Revolution
spinning the sensation Lorenzo backer
like a tractor in cars pulling the
factor
differently saying like a cane in house
supporting uh the lane Marco tun like a
fun still and Fun with Dick and Jane
Rolling the thrill L an American Horse
like force and Air Force One powering
the course simply faded like jaded and
Jade So Sophisticated SJ 94 like Shore
and bayat washing the shore Justin
Martin like a martini and Casino Royale
shaking the scene what there's no
rhyme there's just a bunch of syllables
there are like Rosie batty Darth Yoda
Order 66 like posie and Pushing Daisies
blossoming the Cozy FL Doran like torn
in the torn curtain weaving the
yarn Colin like Rollin in Rolling Kansas
keeping it golden Philip J Smith Jr like
flipping flipper making the script Jen
Smith like Zen in Zen uh calming the den
they didn't even try Melanie LeBlanc
like Swan and Hillary and Jackie rank in
the bank Ron in the bnk M Melanie La
blank like Swank and Hillary and Jackie
ranking the bank all right this is yeah
this is going to put a lot of writers
out of work I think yeah yeah yeah yeah
knows how to write RS it knows poetry it
knows complex interplay between you know
concept this how the Pokemon came up
with the wraps of all the songs Just
yeah here's 150 Pokemon make it rhyme
thanks Chad DPT well guys we appreciate
you all for being here and uh stay tuned
next month to see what we can come up
with next with the help of our lovely
computer assistant love you all see you
[Music]
soon